what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have
another person i'm the official tour
guide i'm jordan peterson okay i'm ready
so we met because you came on my show
yes yeah so tell the people where they
can find you about your podcast yes hey
guys i'm miriam i hope you're all well i
have a podcast called conscious
conversations it's on youtube spotify
apple music just type it in you'll find
it same thing on social media and
official mirror on instagram check me
out and yeah also guys like the video on
your way in subscribe to the channel the
like is the most important thing to the
youtube algorithm so it's really
important that you like the video sign
up for memberships to be a part of our
chat during live streams and we also
have two bonus videos of vlogs that are
on members only so today we're going to
be talking about feminism a little bit
okay we're going to watch jordan
peterson talk to a feminist
so i'm curious how do you feel about
feminism i have always been beaten up on
social media because i've like i just
don't recognize or associate with modern
day feminism i don't even think it is
what it is if that makes sense i don't
think it is what they put out there and
i just i don't know i don't agree i
don't think that there's certain
statements of you know freedom that
equate to a female's freedom so i
wouldn't say a modern day feminist
personally i think i'm more of a
traditionalist when it comes to that
is your family does your family agree
with you on that um somewhat yeah i was
wondering if that's what i like because
my family kind of always taught me to
not go that route so i don't know yeah
yeah yeah again yeah well
okay so this is jordan peterson have you
seen him before yeah i've been familiar
with him i've not seen this though okay
jordan peterson you've said that men
need to quote grow the hell up tell me
why
well because there's nothing
uglier than an old infant
there's nothing good about it
people who don't grow up don't find the
sort of meaning in their life that
sustains them through difficult times
and they're certain to encounter
difficult times
and they're left bitter and resentful
and without purpose and adrift and
hostile and resentful and vengeful and
arrogant and deceitful and and of no use
to themselves and of no use to anyone
else and no partner for a woman and
there's nothing in it that's good so you
say i mean that sounds pretty bad you're
saying there's a crisis of masculinity i
mean what do you do about it
you
tell
you help people understand why
it's necessary and important for them to
grow up and adopt responsibility why
that isn't uh shake your finger and get
your act together sort of thing why it's
more like
why it's more like uh a delineation of
the kind of destiny that makes life
worth living i've been telling young men
and but it's not i wasn't specifically
aiming this message at young men to
begin with it just kind of turned out
that way and it's mostly you admit it's
mostly men listening i mean it is
your audience well it's about 80 on in
on youtube which is a
youtube is a male domain primarily so
it's hard to tell how much of it is
because youtube is male and how how much
of it is because of what i'm saying
but um
you you what i've been telling young men
is that there's an actual reason why
they need to grow up which is that they
have something to offer you know that
that
that people have within them this
capacity to set the world straight and
that's necessary to manifest in the
world and that also doing so is where
you find the meaning that sustains you
in life so what's gone wrong then oh god
all sorts of things have gone wrong i i
think that
i don't think that young men are
hear words of encouragement some some of
them never in their entire lives as far
as i can tell that's what they tell me
and the fact that the words that i've
been that i've been speaking the youtube
lectures that i've done and put online
for example have had such a dramatic
impact is an indication you feel like
people understand how like lonely the
world can be for men i think that's one
of the things that we kind of brush
under the carpet because i think
organically as human beings across the
world no matter how you're raised the
way you live or wherever
we we all have a foundation of a man in
a woman's role to an extent do you know
what i mean and i think i was like even
the first time i was like yeah like i
hear i hear you because i've seen a lot
of um his interviews and his um lectures
and stuff like that and there's a lot of
things that he says that i'm a bit
confused about but i agree i think a lot
of men due to you know not having that
love or that nurturing at a young age
when it gets to a certain point where
they need to pull up their panties and
start doing what they need to do
they can't handle it
and then we completely
look over the fact that they haven't
been nurtured or you know they might be
going through some mental health things
or because they're men and we have this
image and we put them on this pedal
store we also feel like it's not a thing
that affects them do you know what i
mean so it's interesting andrew tate do
you know who that is yeah
yes
but he he talks about how like the women
will never know true loneliness
because there's always it might not be
the guy you want but there's always
someone willing to date a girl yeah at
any age there's always someone
but like men like there's a subset of
men that just like have no purpose i
hate you because like men do things to
get women yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
it's like when you take that away from a
guy like it's like they have nothing to
they're not centered yeah and i think
that's why we have like a generation of
dudes addicted to corn yeah yeah and
like video games yes yes cause it's like
the instant gratification you know it's
interesting because i actually have this
conversation i say men
build and do what they do and get a high
income not purely because of women but a
woman is their catalyst she's what
motivates them and gets them to that
point and a woman is there to be their
support system so that they can continue
to do that when you take that woman's
element out of that picture they can
still build and do what they do but it
won't necessarily be as strong of a
foundation or have that level of
security with it because
what is he doing it for yeah i mean i
think men are definitely like motivated
when they have like a family to come
home to but that's the problem in like
2022 is average girls don't want average
guys anymore yeah and so it's like
there's a subset of men that are like
what am i doing this for
but then you look at it like growing up
in london you know all these young boys
getting into foolishness on the streets
you know and there's this new glorified
addiction to be a particular type of man
and do certain things so you can look a
type of way but ultimately it just it's
purely to impress the woman
you know because women are putting and
projecting these things out there i need
i need a guy that has a bust down chain
and has a nice yeah
and you get 14 15 16 year olds getting
themselves into really bad situations in
order to fit this image that a lot of
these women that are now putting out
there and because it's all on social
media it's unavoidable well that's why
they say like if men are trash like the
women made them that way because that'll
do anything to get laid yeah so yeah so
so it's like it's like if you see a
bunch of dudes not taking girls on dates
and not being like proper gentlemen it's
because we don't want that anymore and
so i think it's even the same thing with
that like girls are picking the futures
over the you know i mean yeah when
they're when they're at their peak so
it's like the men are like i'm tired of
this because people want instant
gratification they want things in the
moment but they're not seeing longevity
they're not saying okay cool i can meet
this person and he ticks a lot of my
boxes you know personality wise x y and
z the things that matter the things that
are going to be long lasting and you can
build with that person they're saying if
he doesn't have a million in the bank if
he doesn't have this then the other and
i don't want him but that's not how life
works that's not our partnership
yeah let's start you also money is a
long game yeah people can get money for
a couple years and lose it
but like like the work ethic that's what
you can't get rid of exactly
let's
young men are starving for this sort of
message because like why in the world
would they have to derive it from a
lecture on youtube now they're not being
taught that they that it's important to
develop yourself but does it does it
bother you that your audience is
predominantly
male does that isn't isn't that a bit
divisive no i don't think so i mean it's
no more divisive than the fact that
youtube is primarily male and tumblers
female isn't it tumblr is primarily
female
but you're just saying that's the way it
is well it's i'm not saying anything
it's just an observation that that's the
way it is um there's plenty of women
that are watching my lectures and coming
to my talks and buying my books it's
just that the majority of them happen to
be men
uh it's what's in it for the women
though
well what sort of partner do you want
you want an overgrown child
or do you want someone to contend with
that's going to help you and then you're
saying women have some sort of duty to
sort of help fix the crisis of
masculinity it depends on what they want
no i mean it's it's exactly exactly how
i laid it out like
women want
deeply want men who are competent and
powerful
and and i don't mean power in in
in the
in that they can exert tyrannical
control over others that's not power
that's just corruption
power is competence
and why in the world would you not want
a competent partner well i i know why
actually you can't dominate a competent
power partner so if you want me you
should dominate is that what you're
saying no i'd say women who have had
their relationships impaired with
impaired
their relationships with men
impaired and who are afraid of such
relationships will settle for a weak
partner because they can dominate them
but it's a sub-optimal solution do you
think there's a lot of women
i think there's a substantial minority
of women who do that and i think it's
very bad for them they're very unhappy
it's very bad for their partners
although the partners get the advantage
of not having to take any responsibility
but what gives you the right to say that
i mean maybe that's how women want their
relationships those women i mean you're
making these vast generalizations
i'm a clinical psychologist right so
you're saying you've done your research
and women are unhappy dominating men
i didn't say they were unhappy
dominating men i said it was a bad
long-term solution okay you said it was
making them miserable yes it is and it
depends on the time frame i mean there
can be there's intense pleasure in
momentary domination that's why people
do it all the time
but it's no formula for a long-term
successful long-term relationship that's
reciprocal right any long-term
relationship is reciprocal
virtually by definition
so
let me put a quote to you from the book
what do you think about what he's
talking about with like dominating i
think the competent stuff makes sense i
think every woman needs and wants a
competent man and the reason why i say
needs and wants is because i think a
healthy successful relationship
needs to have an anchor do you know what
i mean and a competent man is that
anchor you'll keep that and you'll have
that stability long term
um i think it's all very interesting i
think because of what we just spoke
about prior it makes sense a lot of
women are becoming more ceos we're
taking on a lot of traditional male
roles and dominating in the working
world and now people are bringing that
into their home and their personal life
and i think a lot of
human beings don't really know how to
separate between a lot in their life
whether it's personal career
non-personal whatever it may be and this
is where things get lost in translation
you can be a female ceo at work and be
the boss and do your thing when you are
when you're at home with your partner
and your kids are you keeping them
you know and how does that work if you
do keep that with your partner like how
does it make him feel
i don't think most
ceos can switch it off yeah i think it's
kind of who they are yeah to be honest
but like
i i think that girls that make all the
decisions and their relationships hate
their husbands usually um interesting
they're usually like they're usually
like the ball busters
okay no girl wants to lead a
relationship if she's leading and making
the decisions like i they always hate
their husbands that's like sad yeah i do
like
i know i mean i'm sure right now we're
talking about this you could think of a
couple top of your head where she just
wears the pants i hate you i mean they
refer to him like a child well yeah you
know that's not sexy well no honey no no
no you know i think um i actually did an
episode and it was speaking about can
women have it all can women be you know
the boss ceo and come home to her family
and her kids and have her husband be on
job and do what he does and the more we
spoke about it the more we realize that
it's very slim chances that it will work
you can have it yeah but would it work
and when it will it be
what you want it to be will your partner
be that person that you want him to be
you know and yeah it's a very
interesting
outlier especially now at days where
it's so prominent well life's about
trade-offs right so you can have certain
things but you have to trade it off with
something if you're working who's
watching the kids well there you go
someone is if it's not the husband
you're paying someone yeah exactly why
does that hurt like yeah you're paying
someone else to raise your children
exactly i've always thought that was
weird you know having a nanny now yeah
not my kids well you say there are whole
disciplines in universities forthrightly
hostile towards men these are the areas
of study dominated by the post-modern
stroke neo-marxist claim oh i meant to
actually add one more thing i don't
think women are actually like doing
better financially i actually think
they're doing worse but they tell
themselves they're doing better because
even though they may have a high power
position or higher pay they have so much
debt it doesn't even matter yeah so
they're like they'll like act like
they're above these guys
when it's like yeah but you you have all
this debt
and it's probably not as big here but in
the u.s like college debt is huge really
hundreds of thousands of dollars yeah
gosh
yeah yeah and so it's like girls get
these four-year degrees and then think
they're like so educated and above these
men when it's like the dude dude went to
the plumbing school and like he's making
a good salary like i don't understand
why girls think they're above trade
workers i hate you to me it's very
attractive if a guy like can if he's
like handy yeah yeah yeah
like the labor work yeah like i could
i'd marry me
but girls will like act like they're
above it because they're not like
educated like it's stupid stuff like
that but it's because a lot of girls
nowadays are a bit deluded in what they
want in a partner they're just a bit
like we're so consumed in social media
and music and what these rappers and
what these artists are saying and what
has been put out there on television all
this sort of stuff that like what you
want in a partner is so distorted when
what you're seeing is a minority of
people that even achieve that anyways
and it's not all rainbows and you know i
mean like it's actually the opposite
like hollywood and like rap like they
don't have good relationships like yeah
but it's still glorified like it's like
for watching for once
western culture in particular is an
oppressive structure created by white
men to dominate and exclude women
but then i want to put minorities too
dominating okay sure but i want to put
you that here in the uk for example
let's take that as an example the gender
pay gap stands at just over nine percent
you've got women at the bbc recently
saying that the broadcaster is illegally
paying them less than men to do the same
job you've got only seven women running
the top ftse 100 companies
so it seems to a lot of women that
they're still being dominated and
excluded to quote your words back to you
it does seem that way but
multivariate analysis of the pay gap
indicate that it doesn't exist
but that's just true is it i mean that's
nine percent
that's a gap between median hourly
earnings between men and women but that
exists yeah but there's multiple reasons
for that one of them is gender but it's
not the only reason like if you're a
social scientist worth worth your salt
you never do a univariate analysis
like you say well women in aggregate are
paid less than men okay well then we
break it down by age we break it down by
occupation we break it down by interest
we break it down by personality but
you're saying basically it doesn't
matter if women aren't getting to the
top because that's what's skewing that
gender pay gap isn't it you're saying
well that's just a fact of nothing
how are you going to get to the top no
i'm not saying it doesn't matter either
you're saying there are multiple reasons
for it yeah but those reasons why why
should women put up with those reasons
why should
i'm saying that the claim
that the wage gap between men and women
is only due to sex is wrong and it is
wrong there's no doubt about that the
multivariate analysis have been done
multi-varied analysis
i'm saying that nine percent pay gap
exists that's a gap between men and
women i'm not saying why it exists but
it exists now if you're a woman that
seems pretty unfair
you have to say why it exists but do you
agree that it's unfair if you're a woman
not necessarily and on average you're
getting paid 9 less than a man that's
not fair is it
it depends on why it's happening
i can give you an example
okay
there's a personality trait known as
agreeableness
agreeable people are compassionate and
polite
and agreeable people get paid less than
just less agreeable people for the same
job
women are more agreeable than men again
a vast generalization sometimes
that's true but that's right and some
women get paid more than men
so you were saying that by and large
women are too agreeable to get the pay
rises so i'm saying that that's one
component of a multivariate equation
that predicts
um salary
it accounts for maybe five percent of
the variance something like that so
surely we need about another 20 we
needed about another 18 factors one of
which is gender and there is prejudice
there's no doubt about that but it
accounts for a much smaller proportion
of the variance in the pay gap than the
radical feminists claim okay so rather
than denying the pay gap exists which is
what you did at the beginning of this
conversation shouldn't you say to women
rather than being agreeable and not
asking for a pay rise go and ask for a
pay right make yourself disagreeable
with your book oh definitely there's
that but i also didn't deny it existed i
denied it it existed because of gender
okay because i'm very very
very
careful with my words
so the pay gap exists you accept that
but you're saying
i mean the pay gap between men and women
exists but you're saying it's not
because of gender it's because women are
too agreeable to ask for pay rises one
of the reasons okay one of the reasons
so why not get them to ask for a pay
right i've done that
many many times in my career and they
just counseled oh they do it all the
time you can it's so one of the things
that you do as a clinical psychologist
is um assertiveness training so you
might say
often you treat people for anxiety you
treat them for depression
um
and you and maybe the next most common
category after that would be
assertiveness training and so i've had
many many women extraordinarily
competent women in my clinical
consulting practice and we put together
strategies for their career development
that involve continual pushing competing
for higher wages and often tripled their
wages within a five-year period
you celebrate
of course so
do you actually do you agree that you
would be happy
if that pay gap was eliminated
completely because that's all the
radical feminists are saying it would
depend on how it was eradicated and how
the how how the disappearance of it was
measured and you're saying
the cost of men that's a problem oh
there's all sorts of things that it
could be at the cost of it could even be
at the cost of women's own interests
so because they might not be happy if
they get equal pay
no because it might interfere with other
things that are causing the pay gap that
women are choosing today like having
children
well or choosing careers that actually
happen to be paid less which women do a
lot of but why shouldn't women have the
right to choose not to have children or
the right to choose those demanding they
do they can
yeah that's fine but you're saying that
makes them unhappy by and large i'm
saying that that no i'm not saying that
i'm i and i actually haven't said that
so far you're saying it makes them
miserable no i said that what was making
them miserable was having part was
having weak partners
that makes them miserable right um i
would say that many women around the age
of i would say between 28 and 32 have a
career family crisis that they have to
deal with and i think that's partly
because of the foreshortened time frame
that women have to contend with like
women have to
get the major pieces of their life put
together faster than men which is also
partly why men aren't under so much
pressure to grow up so because for the
typical woman
she has to have her career and family in
order
pretty much by the time she's 35 because
otherwise the options start to
[Music]
so what do you think i agree that makes
sense it makes like even if we're
talking biologically women have a
biological clock
men don't right so
men i do believe that men have a lot of
pressure career-wise but i think when it
comes to actually having your life being
put together it makes more sense like a
woman especially if you want to have
kids if you want to do all the
traditional family things you need to
make sure that you do before a certain
point you need to make sure your health
is in check you need to make sure that
you're even bringing enough money home
if you're a single a single woman to
even take care of your kid and bring
your kid into this world and then also
find a partner that you know is willing
to raise your kid with you and all these
sort of things that a lot of women
desire at um anything between 21 to like
35 do you know i mean even older so i
think that makes sense i think a lot of
us women have a lot more subconscious
pressure when it comes to getting our
lives in order i think men have that
also but from the opposite perspective
like a lot of men will just get a woman
pregnant and then now they're like okay
i need to get my [ __ ] together
and you know do what i need to do but a
lot of a lot of men might find somebody
and you know start a family of that
person and realize okay cool this is the
time for me now to boss up and do what i
need to do as a man and i think even
though the man has a big part to play in
it it's on the woman's time clock does
that make sense why do you think
feminism tells women they have all the
time in the world when so it's
interesting because they they say like
you can do the career first
but 90 of your eggs are gone by 30. and
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35 and
even if you get ivf it's 25 000 per year
yeah which i don't i think it's like i
don't know 17 000 pounds but like most
people don't have that yeah so it's like
a luxury lifestyle people are pushing on
average people
but then we're talking about the same
people that
will
decide not to have kids
you know and decide that that's the path
that they want to take so i think that's
a cope well i think most people at 18
wanted kids yeah something happened
along the way where they didn't maybe
they got their heart broke yeah a lot
you know a lot of young girls you know
were sat here planning our weddings
you know at a young age you know we
think about these things so i think i
think the whole idea of you know put
your career first i i hear it i think
definitely build something for yourself
as a woman i think that's very important
but biology is biology you know like
it's literally forbidden what it is and
you can't you can't push out this
deluded idea that women have all the
time in the world because we don't you
know a lot of women will do their career
career career and then hit 45 and want a
kid yeah and it's been over for them
yeah ten years do you know what i mean
what do you what do you think about what
are you saying about the pay gap because
in my experience girls that complain
about the pay gap are typically lazy
no i'm serious because i'm like as as a
young woman this is my point of view
you're in an advantage like okay you're
you're a pretty girl you go into most
places that like they're hiring most men
are going to be attracted to you right
like just just
say like just by in the fact that you're
young and attractive i think most girls
under the age of 30 like they're at an
advantage over men because the world
looks at young men as they're as if
they're disposable yeah where like young
woman you're born with value
i think it's i agree that women are born
of value and i agree that men have to
make that value i think that's something
that's very evident i think that women
have a lot more
opportunities if you open your eyes a
bit more like stuff like that i have you
know i i used to waitress i growing up
like do you know i mean i've been
working since the age of 14 so i've been
in the working mode for ages and i've
gone to loads of different places and
they said they'd only hire pretty women
because pretty women bring in customers
yes and it's a really real thing and i
think that the paid gap is real
like if we're gonna look at it on a very
surface level obviously i understand
that there's other reasons outside of
gender as to why it happens whatever
that is i'm not as knowledgeable in that
but i would say that women just need to
be a bit more smart
i think because we're not necessarily
conditioned
from the past generations to be working
and the bringing all the meat home and
all this sort of stuff we don't know how
to conduct ourselves and whatever the
average woman works 32 hours per week
the average man works 40. well yeah yeah
and so it's like i just like that's why
i say i think most girls that complain
about not getting paid i'm sure you've
never had an issue getting money well no
i mean yeah yeah yeah there's a will
there's a way yeah yeah i have the same
like mindset yeah because i think if i
work hard at something i can do good at
it
and i just think that's like a mindset
but feminism has this
mindset that the world's against them
instead of like playing to your
advantages yeah it's a victim mentality
like there's a point where you just need
to
stop blaming the world and look at your
own life like stop looking at everything
else outside of you look at your own
life send it to yourself look at what
you can do and what changes you can make
and just start and go and do what you
need to do
i've never been one to sit here and be
like oh i'm because i'm a minority woman
and i'm a muslim woman like yeah certain
things are evident you're going to get
prejudiced you're going to get it's
going to be more difficult for you to
get into certain careers if you're a
minority point blank that's very evident
it's there but am i going to sit here
and complain about it no i'm going to go
and break the walls down and make sure
that my presence is heard and do what i
want to do and make that happen for
myself
and i think a lot of people just don't
have that mentality anymore
right now and so that puts a tremendous
amount of stress on women especially at
the end of their twenties i think i take
issue with the idea of the typical woman
because you know all women are different
and that's what i want to just put
another quote to you from the book
different in some ways and the same in
others
okay you say women become more
vulnerable when they have children and
you talk to one of your youtube
interviews about crazy happy sisters
so
simple question is gender equality a
myth in your view is that something
that's just never going to happen
it depends on what you mean by equality
getting the same opportunities
fairly people could we could get to a
point where people were treated fairly
or more fairly i mean people are treated
pretty fairly in western culture already
but we can they're really not though are
they i mean otherwise why would there
only be seven women running footsy 100
companies in the uk why why would there
still be a pay gap which we've discussed
why are women at the bbc saying that
they're getting paid illegally less than
men to do the same job that's not fair
let's go to the first question there
brothers are complicated questions seven
seven women repeat that one there's
seven women running the top ftse 100
companies in the uk well the first the
first question might be um why would you
want to do that
why would a man want to do it
there's a lot of money
there's a certain number of of men
although not that many
who are perfectly willing to sacrifice
virtually all of their life
to the pursuit of a high-end career so
they'll work these are men that are very
intelligent they're usually very very
conscientious they're very driven
they're very high energy they're very
healthy and they're willing to work 70
or 80 hours a week non-stop specialized
at one thing to get to the top so you
say women are just more sensible they
don't want that because it's not an
isolated i'm saying that's part of it
definitely and so i work
you don't think there are barriers in
their way that prevent them getting to
the top there are some barriers yeah
like other like men for example i mean
to get to the top of any organization is
an incredibly competitive enterprise and
the men that you're competing with are
simply not going to roll over and say
please take the position
absolutely all out warfare is gender
equality a myth
i don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable
if it means equality of outcome then
almost certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in scandinavia
because in scandinavia i mean by that
equality of outcome is undesirable well
men and women won't sort themselves into
the same categories if you leave them
alone to do it off their own accord i've
already seen that in scandinavia it's 20
to one female nurses to male something
like that it might not be quite that
extreme and approximately the same male
engineers to female engineers and that's
a consequence of the free choice of men
and women in the societies that have
gone farther than any other societies to
make gender equality the purpose of the
law those are inerraicable differences
you can eradicate them with tremendous
social pressure and tyranny but if you
leave men and women to make their own
choices you will not get equal outcomes
right so you're saying that anyone who
believes in equality whether you call
them feminists call them whatever you
want to call them should basically give
up because it ain't going to happen only
if they're aiming at equality of outcome
so you're saying give people equality
of opportunity that's fine it's not only
fine it's eminently desirable for
everyone for individuals and for society
but still women aren't going to make it
that's what you're really saying depends
on your measurement techniques they're
doing just fine in medicine
in fact there are far more female
physicians than there are male
physicians
there are lots of lots of disciplines
that are absolutely dominated by women
many many disciplines and they're doing
great
so let me put something else to you from
the book you say the introduction of the
equal pay for equal work argument
immediately complicates even salary
comparison beyond practicality for one
simple reason who decides what work is
equal it's not possible so the simple
question is do you believe in equal pay
well i made the argument there it's like
it depends so you don't believe in equal
pay
no i'm not saying that at all because a
lot of people listening to you will just
say i mean are we going back to the
doctor you're actually not listening
very carefully and i'm hearing you
basically saying women need to just
accept they're never going to make it on
equal terms equal outcomes is what how
you defined it no idea if i was a young
woman watching that i would go well i
might as well just go and play with my
cindy dolls i'd give up trying at school
because i'm not going to get the top job
i want because there's someone sitting
there saying it's not possible
that's what i said it's a it's a bad
social goal i didn't say that women
shouldn't be striving for the top or
anything like that because i don't
believe that for a second striving for
the top but you're going to put all
those hurdles in their way as has been
in their way for centuries and that's
fine you're saying that's fine no no i
think i really the patriarchal system is
just that's silly i do i think that's
silly i really do i mean look look at
your situation you're hardly
unsuccessful yeah and i have how do you
make it hard to get exactly
good that's okay battling is good this
is almost inevitable but you talk about
men fighting let me just put another
thing to you from the back you're saying
you have to battle for a high quality
position
well i notice in your book you talk
about real conversations between men
containing like doesn't listen yeah i
was going to say what is your opinion on
how she's receiving all this information
because i just feel like
it's just bouncing off her and she has
all these things in her head that she
wants to get through i think there's a
reason this video got 38 million views
whoa
yeah like because she it's crazy when
they put this out they thought she
looked good that's like how delusional
feminists star
they thought that she was like
super easy and open to like talk to no
it's because she's aggressively trying
to push out a point that aligns with
them in it so that's what i mean when i
say like most of the people that
complained about the pay gap are just
lazy if you want to get make a [ __ ] ton
of money you have to do a [ __ ] ton of
work yeah and that's the thing i grew up
in a family that like is part of like
the half a percent right my dad my dad
owns a software company and he employs
like two 300 people like but i saw the
work that goes into it he worked 80
hours a week so it's like it's like 12
hour days
for
like he used to just get up at like
three in the morning he couldn't sleep
he would just go to the office yeah and
like he did this for 20 30 years wow and
so it's like
i wouldn't want to do that yeah yeah
most women wouldn't want like they don't
have that in them and that's not there's
nothing wrong with that yeah yeah like i
think that's perfectly fine but like
girls want all the like this is my issue
with feminism is girls want all the
benefits without any of the
responsibility and they like and even
even in like this stuff you're going to
act like we're at such a disadvantage
when we have quotas right yeah it's like
how do you feel about like quotas hmm
i find them offensive
i
would you mean you find them offensive i
can get the job myself i don't need your
quota yeah well there you go that's what
yeah i just think it's a bit silly more
than offensive do you know what i mean i
think like you said if i can get the job
on my own i don't need to be hearing
about your quota i don't need that to
even be in my vicinity like i'll get the
job done and keep it moving do you know
what i mean um i don't know i just think
the whole thing is a bit i think a lot
of this stuff is just a bit silly
overall to be honest have you heard the
stats he's talking about with the pay
gap have you heard that before like the
reasons for it i have heard yeah yeah
yeah i have heard it before i feel like
jordan peterson just like
when he when he got into like media
he really dismantled the pay gap because
you can't argue with a man who like
has been helping women exactly yeah and
i think that's the biggest thing that
needs to be acknowledged is that i've
watched a lot of his
videos and a lot of his lectures and i
think there's a lot more benefit for
women and what he says
than men anyways and when you find out
and he tells you and it brings you in
and shows you you know i've helped x-men
women do excellent things
what is there for you to be angry about
yeah there might be one or two things
that you may disagree with because
evidently you're human your life is not
exactly the same
100 exactly
but people need to learn to filter
through people's perspectives and their
mentality there's certain things you can
take from them and learn and there's
certain things that you just need to
leave there and that's fine well and
this is a perfect example of like
hitting the hand that feeds you or
what's that phrase because he's out
there doing the work like helping women
get paid more exactly and then he goes
on the show and this feminist is
treating him like this it's like
shouldn't you what are you doing yeah
what are you doing
an underlying threat of physicality oh
there's no doubt about that what about
real conversation between women is that
something are we sort of too amenable
and reasonable
no it's just that
the domain of physical conflict is sort
of off limits for you
well you just said that i fought to get
where i've got yeah but what does that
mean well i don't know
i don't imagine that you've yeah to some
degree i suspect you're not very
agreeable so that's the thing success
for women i'm not very
don't
agreeable
right
actually in this conversation at least
and i'm sure it served your career well
successful women though
basically have to wear the trousers in
your view they have to sort of become
men to succeed is what you're saying
well if they're i've had to fight to
succeed therefore
masculine traits are going to be helpful
i mean one of the things i do
in in my counseling practice for example
when i'm consulting with women who are
trying to advance their careers is to
teach them how to negotiate and to and
to be able to say no and to not be
easily pushed around and to be
formidable and you need to if you're
going to be successful you need to be
smart conscientious and tough well
here's a radical idea why don't the
bosses adopt some the male bosses shall
we say adopt some female traits so that
women don't have to fight and get their
sharp elbows out for the pay rises it's
just accepted if they're doing the same
job they get the same pay
well i would say actually fun fact 60 of
women have never asked for a raise and
they'll quit before they ask for a raise
yeah and also i have a really big issue
with this whole why don't we ask or why
don't we get other people to get it that
stop focusing on what you can't control
like if it's out of your hands it's out
of your hands like stuff like that
really irritates me because i just think
babe if you're gonna go up to your your
boss or whoever and be like well you
should adopt more female traits so i
understand that it's a thing there's
barriers there for the vast masses of
women in the working world but who is do
you think your boss is going to be like
okay and adopts that and keeps it moving
like no it's not going to happen you
need to play the game how the game is
set you can't come and change the game
and expect it to just be all breezy and
it's just going to change the world like
like it doesn't work like that i think
that argument is just really pointless i
really don't like when people project
and look at everybody else but
themselves well and they also like
you realize men built everything
it's a man's world yeah yeah it's a man
and so it's like you're gonna go to the
institution like imagine if we did a
female run company and men came into it
yeah and they said oh run it like this
it's like
yeah you'd think they were nuts
exactly so you're going to go into the
companies that they built and tell them
how to run it yeah yeah like you know
yeah yeah exactly the audacity the
audacity honestly partly because it's
not so easy to determine what
constitutes the same job and almost
because
arguably yeah there are still men
dominating our industries our society
and therefore they've dictated the terms
for so long that women have to battle to
know that's not true
it's not true so for example
well i can give you another
misconception i don't know why we look
at women throughout history as oppressed
yeah like we were
like certain men were second-class
citizens women most women were looked at
as more valuable than that 100 and like
we didn't have to go to war yeah yeah
and like a lot of times people will use
like the right to vote right as a reason
for why women are oppressed but it came
with responsibility
and like that's what feminism always is
it's it's like freedom but without the
responsibility like they wanted to vote
without the ability to get drafted yeah
but that's the whole point of getting
drafted is so you have some skin in the
game if you if you elect someone that's
batshit crazy like that's an incentive
you know what yeah yeah and you've
picked that and you've been a part of
that choice yeah there's something that
needs to come with that you know
and i think looking the whole thing with
history as well if you look back 10 not
even 10 not even 100 years ago yeah
traditionally all over the world except
for certain places in the west when a
woman would get married to a man and i'm
talking outside of faith i'm just
talking cultural
but before the man marries the woman he
has to give her um
and the whole purpose of the dowry was
if anything was to happen to this woman
you know she could use that dowry to get
herself out of a certain situation so it
was completely hers and it's purely for
her safety yeah right yes but if you
look back during those periods of time
in the west and in
certain places in asia it was the other
way around so the women in the west when
they wanted to marry a man their woman's
family had to provide dowry for the man
oh really interesting and i i remember i
remember looking into that and i thought
this makes
a little more sense now as to why like
women in the west have
developed this sense of modern feminism
and this sense of mentality because over
here it's just always been a bit more
weird like the value of women back then
to an extent has never really
fully come through do you know what i
mean so women within themselves even
know how to value themselves now well i
think it's because the product is worse
like yeah well yeah that's endless
that's what i think a lot of times like
women are asking for traditional
outcomes but you're not traditional
i don't like i don't think i'm
traditional because if you're
traditional you'd be married before 25.
like and and i'm sorry you'd be a virgin
yeah of course and so so it's like
women are asking yeah women are asking
for like top shelf prices yeah yeah and
like i always see girls quote this book
um have you seen why men love [ __ ]
yes
but it's it's toxic because it's like
again it's telling women to raise their
price
but not increase their value yeah and
that's that's the thing like what like
this is it doesn't and men aren't stupid
and that's that's the problem i have
with like western women is like humble
yourself yeah fully humble yourself
because it's
it's it's a very
modern women are side chicks well yeah
it's a very interesting that way of life
is just very interesting because like
you said if you're
not a modern woman
you can't expect a traditional man
to reciprocate what you want it doesn't
work you're like the puzzle piece
doesn't make sense and also men are a
lot more clued up or a lot more they're
like i'm game now yeah they're a lot
more glued up than women will ever think
and unless you've been around enough men
or you surrounded yourself in spaces
where you can understand how they think
you'll never know that
so all these women that are out here on
social media screaming the most doing
the most and wanting the most do you
even know what type of man you're asking
about or wanting i feel like a lot of
times they're just angry they can't get
that attention anymore yeah i think a
lot of women are um
in simple terms attention seekers
they just want the attention and they
want it from a man if they want it from
a small percentage of men and the second
it goes away they get angry but also
they they want it from that man so they
can show it off to other women and be
like well i look i'm this girl and i got
this guy and it's like yeah women are
always in competition with each other as
well that's a big thing an example very
quickly so i worked with women who
worked in high-powered law firms in
canada for about 15 years and they were
as
competent and put together as anybody
you would ever meet and we were trying
to figure out how to further their
careers
and there was a huge debate in canadian
society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the law firms didn't
use these masculine criteria then
perhaps women would do better but the
market sets the damn game it's like and
the market is dominated by men
it's not the market is dominated by
women they make 80 of the consumer
decisions that's not the case at all if
you're talking about people who stay at
home looking after children by and large
they are still women so they're going
out doing the shopping but that has
changed they make all these
questions okay so what are they not true
women owned two thirds of the debt we're
just bad with money it's driven by women
not men right okay and if you're a
lawyer they still pay more for the same
sort of goods
that's been proven that men for the you
buy a blue bicycle helmet it's going to
cost less than a pink one anyway we'll
come on to that partly because men are
less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it i
want to ask you
is it not desirable to have some of
those female traits you're talking about
i'd say that's a generalization but
you've used the words female traits is
it not desirable to have some of them at
the top of business i mean maybe they
wouldn't they don't predict that banking
crisis they don't predict success in the
workplace the things that predict
success in the workplace are
intelligence and conscientiousness
agreeableness negatively predicts
success in the workplace
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these top
companies no i didn't say that at all
you said that
female traits don't predict success but
i didn't say that intelligence wasn't i
didn't say that intelligence and
conscientiousness well you were saying
by implication are not female traits no
no i mean that's very dangerous not
saying that at all are women less
intelligent than men no no they're not
no the the data on that's pretty clear
the average iq for a woman in the
average iq for man is identical there is
some debate about the flatness of the
distribution which is something that
james demoure pointed out for example in
his memo but there's no difference at
all in general cognitive ability there's
no difference to speak of in
conscientiousness women are a bit more
orderly than men and men are a little
bit more industrious than women but the
difference isn't big i don't think that
averages into any men who aren't
necessarily well of course
why are they not feminine treats why are
they not desirable at the top of
feminine traits why are they not
desirable at the top it's hard to say
i'm just laying out the empirical
evidence like we know that we know the
traits that predict success but we also
know because companies by and large have
not been dominated by women over the
centuries we have nothing to compare it
to it's an experiment true and it could
be the case that if companies modified
their behavior and became more feminine
they would be successful but there's no
evidence for it i'm not neither doubtful
nor non-doubtful there's no evidence why
not give it a go as the radical because
the evidence suggests well it's fine if
like if someone wants to start a company
and make it more feminine and
compassionate let's say and caring in
its overall orientation towards its
workers and towards the marketplace then
that's a perfectly reasonable experiment
to run my point is that there is no
evidence that those traits predict
success in the workplace and there's
positivity
well that's not that's not really the
case women have been in the workplace
for what at least
ever since i've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries let me move
on to another debate that's been very
controversial for you um
and this is you got in trouble for she's
not listening yeah
yeah at all
i think she just has like
tunnel vision of what she's trying to
get out there yeah and just not even
taking it in but then this is a general
thing a lot of people just don't listen
they don't want to hear the facts they
just they're they're very emotion
focused in when they speak and that
passion comes out comes out comes out
that it blocks out any form of logic
that could be reciprocated well i'm just
of the opinion like if you get new
information you didn't know why wouldn't
you change your opinion yeah like and so
you're never going to learn anything if
you don't listen she has someone that
knows what like i feel like our
generation doesn't know when to shut the
[ __ ] up yeah 100
like because if you meet someone that's
been doing this for 20 30 years like up
i'm gonna i'm gonna shut up and let him
talk i'll listen i'll question it so i
can find out more like there's nothing
wrong with that yeah but when you come
with like you already have your opinion
and you're very strong with it and
but you don't have all the knowledge to
back it up
like surely when you're here this is the
fact this is what's been going on this
has been proven
you can sit back and be like oh okay i
didn't know that or oh okay let me look
into that a bit more and come back and
see how i feel about that like there's
certain it's okay to be wrong and it's
also okay to not know enough about
a specific topic or a specific thing
that might come up in conversation like
it's fine you don't have to know
everything but i think a lot of women i
think a lot of men do this too
it's a pressure thing like when you're
pride and ego and certain things are
involved
like you don't want to back down because
it looks weak
and ironically she's trying to present
herself as a very strong woman which if
you look at it it's a masculine trait so
it all fits into the same bubble but
this is what i mean women can't turn it
off does she seem like she'd be fun to
be married to
does she seem like she'd be like a good
a good time a good wife you you come
home and she's just like ready to battle
already well she said she's um
disagreeable so
how using to call trans men and women by
their preferred personal pronouns
no that's not actually true i got in
trouble actually so
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna explain this
situation so he was from canada okay and
there was a law passed in canada
requiring people to call trans people by
their pronouns okay by their chosen
pronoun yeah okay and he's saying that's
that law is unlawful because you're
telling me what i can and cannot say
so it wasn't really about the trans
issue it was about the freedom of speech
issue okay but the trans community kind
of took it and tried to make him a
villain
even though like that's not he's but i'm
just just to give you a little bit of
context
because i said i would not follow the
compelled speech dictates of the federal
and provincial government i actually
never got in trouble for not calling
anyone anything right that didn't happen
wouldn't follow the change of law which
was designed once it was law
discrimination no no no
he said it was designed to do okay you
cited freedom of speech in that why
should your right to freedom of speech
trump a trans person's
right not to be offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive i mean look
at the conversation we're having right
now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather
uncomfortable well i'm i'm very glad i
put you on this part
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell is
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine i think more power to
you as far as i'm concerned
except you haven't sat there and
i'm just right i'll just try to work
that out i mean
ha gotcha you have got me you have got
me i'm trying to work that through my
head yeah yeah it took a while took a
while it did yeah took a while
you have voluntary you have voluntarily
come into the studio and agreed to be
questioned
a trans person in your class has come to
your class and said they wouldn't be
called that's never happened
and i would call them she so you would
so you've kind of changed your channel
no no no i said that right from the
beginning what i said at the beginning
was that i was not going to cede the
linguistic territory to radical leftists
regardless of whether or not it was put
in law
that's what i said and then the people
who came after me said well you must be
transphobic and you'd mistreat a student
in your class it's like i never
mistreated a student in my class i'm not
transphobic and that isn't what i said
well except you've also called trans
campaigners authoritarian have you i
mean isn't that only in the broader
context of my claims that radical
leftist ideologues are i think i'm
transphobic interesting how's your name
well because i think they're delusional
i don't think just because you dress up
like a a girl or a guy you can be one
and i think requiring everyone to do
that like making you them live in your
delusion yeah like what if i said i'm
black yeah well that's what it is so i i
i think that's the one thing out of like
the lgbtq
bubble that i've just never understood
and i've spoken to a lot of people that
identify with that title and within that
group as trans we'll bring them on the
show
on the show
and you know um i had a conversation
with a really close friend of mine who
is gay and he couldn't even not that i
would expect him to but he couldn't even
educate me enough for me to have any
form of clarity or understanding within
that sector of the lgbtq plus community
and i think cross-dressing like you can
cross just honey do like do do what you
want i'd rather they do i mean but you
know i'd rather if that's what you're
going to do your body yeah you can do
too much
that's what you're going to do do that i
think when it comes to like a biological
change and you know taking medication to
suppress certain natural bodily things
and xyz for me it's i don't know enough
but it doesn't sit right with me i don't
get it i don't understand how
how well and as a as a female athlete i
find it very offensive
okay like the leah thomas thing i was
very outspoken you know leah thomas
because i know how little opportunity
there is in women's sports yeah i know
how hard like we are like women's
athletes are the hardest working group
because we don't do it for the money yes
and is hard right but we don't there was
nobody at the end of this i know
such talented athletes yeah that get
contracts in europe and just the fact
that they got a contract is is huge but
it's not they get free housing and like
a thousand two thousand bucks a month
yeah yeah yeah there's no there's no
payout yeah at the end of it yeah and
the little opportunity that we have
you're gonna give to the dudes
i have like i don't know what i worked
for 12 years for this and you're just
gonna try and it's like people that
understand those moments in sports mean
so much to us like athletes like we
could be done with the game in 10 years
we could still tell you how some game
ended 10 years ago like i could tell you
how my last high school the last point
in my high school career that was that
was eight years ago
and i'll probably be able to tell you
that for another 10 years yeah and those
moments mean so much and so like the
moments that trans people have taken
from biological women like we can't get
those back i agree i think it comes down
to and it starts with allowing delusions
but it's also who whose emotions
matter the most now or matter more
because when things like that have been
like you said you know
by buying into it you're buying into a
delusion but what makes your emotion
more valuable than theirs or vice versa
because i've had plenty conversations
where i feel like certain things have
been pushed down your throat
because it has to be accepted it has to
be this it has to be that but you know
i'm a muslim woman i can't be fully
covered at a local swimming pool i have
to wear a bikini or a normal and have my
skin out so how do these things work
like why are we so selective wait why do
you have to wear a bikini it's policy
you can't wear like a fully like even
though it's a swimsuit it could be like
it could be whoever is policy you can't
wear it at the pool oh that's [ __ ] up
though yeah it's crazy that's [ __ ] up
it's silly like it's and it's like so
you couldn't wear like a a long sleeve
whatever because i've been to dubai yeah
and then the girls would wear these like
they're just they're swimsuits they're
just long sleeves yeah yeah oh my gosh
yeah they don't let you that's so i'm
like a pole honey in france france is a
whole another topic like my aunt she's a
teacher in france you can't work in any
form of institution with your hair
covered so she'll walk and then at the
school gates she has to remove her scarf
and um like if she's wearing like a
buyer she'll remove her which is the one
dress she'll remove that and she'll have
to change into like trousers on the top
and have her hair out and teach and then
when she's leaving she puts her scarf
back on like it's it's stupid it's crazy
that's so stupid and then you know the
french law will say oh well we're not
islamophobic it's just policy and it's
no religious symbols which they back up
by saying in schools you know you can't
wear like a
a cross with a necklace or any form of
religious symbols but you can't say that
in the workplace do you know what i mean
and how does that even make any sense
like why does that bother you so much so
it's it's understanding what matters if
we're going to put everything on a level
playing field let's not pick and choose
who you know gets all these benefits and
we have to accept x y and z
but then you're doing i i cannot believe
they don't let you wear a freaking
because of anything we should get rid of
the freaking thong bikinis there's
children or like if there's anything wow
if there's anything we should ban thong
kitties i am so tired of seeing your
butt cheeks and that's the two i am so
tired of seeing y'all bunching i don't
want to see this i'm straight i'm
straight but i don't know i don't think
that's the same thing as like
trans people it's not the same but i'm
saying it's it's the idea of like are we
gonna really dictate who's emotional his
emotional stability is worth more
because that's how i see it if you're
gonna if you're gonna you know it
depends what you mean by dictate i don't
know like for like i'm all for if you
want to if you want to go chop off your
day and do all that dress like a person
like the opposite yeah but it's like
it's when you're forcing your delusion
on other people that's what i'm saying
so like emotional everyone's different
everyone's raised different everyone has
different backgrounds everybody wants to
live their life how they want to live it
do you don't expect everybody around you
or every industry or every person in the
world
to accept that like because they won't
you know what i mean but when it's so
publicly pushed out there it is it's
like you said it's buying into the
delusion of like
yeah i'm shocked i just can't believe
they don't let you wear a scarf at work
like that's crazy to me yeah
the u.s like they would like as far as i
know you guys can correct me in the
comments but they just don't have stuff
like that you're allowed to do what you
want as long as like like i wouldn't be
for anyone at a non-religious school
pushing their religion on to the student
yes like anyone regardless but like if
how does a scarf that's what i'm saying
like if i'm a teacher and i'm teaching
math yeah but i've just got a head scarf
on i'm not pushing yeah and that's what
i'm saying
but if it's a fashion choice
it's acceptable
that's crazy do you know what i mean
because why what is the reason in muslim
culture they can't show their hair so
it's it's for your husband is that what
it is so there's it's it's a very
layered thing so it all fits under the
term modesty but it doesn't so in arabic
a word can mean multiple things so by
definition it's not just the physical
element of modesty it's the mental it's
the exclusivity it's the fact that women
are of such high value that they
shouldn't allow all of their energy all
of their physical and mental being to be
out there okay it comes down to the way
you speak it comes down to how you dress
it comes down to a lot of things it's
not just you know you cover up and
that's what it is and you're oppressed
now your husband your your family
everybody that is closest to you and has
a genuine relationship with you is
allowed to tap into all of that it's
just not meant to be accessible to the
rest of the world
um yeah i've had a lot of guys from like
the manosphere tell me they seek out
muslim women because they're more
traditional and they're not hoes go they
said they're like i'm so tired of these
things
and like like a lot of them will tell me
they'll literally go to muslim countries
to get the women because like they're
just like higher quality on muslim
dating apps there was a scandal that
came up a couple months ago saying that
most i think there was a percentage i'm
not too sure what the percentage was but
there was a percentage of men that were
on the app who weren't muslim men
seeking muslim women as wives and on
certain dating apps like um especially
within the muslim community you have to
be able to think because a muslim woman
can't marry a non-muslim man that's
going to be my question yeah actually so
a muslim man can marry a woman that is
muslim jewish or christian because our
foundations of abrahamic faith is the
same and a man is what passes down the
faith and the culture to the kids but a
woman can't because obviously a man
passes everything down so and i
personally as a muslim woman wouldn't
want to marry somebody that's not
missing because i would want my husband
to to step up and take that is that hard
here that's got to be a smaller pool
isn't it yeah let me tell you
my sisters i know you've been struggling
out here in these streets it's hard and
i think what makes it even harder is
when you're born in the west
and there are certain things that aren't
necessarily aligned for your moral
compass it's hard like even you if even
me as a muslim woman like it's
there's going to be certain
situations or spaces or whatever that i
will be in whether it's career school
whatever that don't necessarily fall in
line or fit within the moral standpoint
like and
you know it's written that that's that's
okay that's evident because the more
time get um the further along we go
in time the more modern and the more
like western things will become so it's
written that that is understandable but
it's hard because trying to be um
consistently stable within your moral
standpoint within your faith whatever
faith it may be when you're in a land
that doesn't support that or isn't for
that or doesn't really give you
much to go off it's difficult to stay
consistent and to be on top of it yeah i
mean i'm just thinking like if you meet
a muslim guy here who's like good
looking and successful i bet he probably
cause i'm sure all the muslim girls are
like yeah on it right so it's probably
really competitive it's competitive and
it's also
like a lot of muslim men have
gone down a non-muslim man's path
whether it be the ways in which they
make money
or
the people they hang around with or they
want to go and you know drink and party
and do certain things because all the
boys are doing it and all the lads are
doing it and do you not drink i don't
know oh that's it i don't either yeah
so
yes
i have enough alcohol you think right
okay
i was like okay bottles no no it's so
it's just for the guests
okay why don't you drink um i did in
college i just felt like the costs
outweighed the benefits i hated and i
was just like honestly i was getting fat
like
well the calories yeah and i was i was
just in a heart like it wasn't
necessarily like a lot of people think
i'm super religious right and i wouldn't
say i'm like crazy religious i'm just
like it's like you go to the gym every
week i do all this work just to do to
what drink again yeah i can go back on
it yeah i already am addicted to sugar
like well exactly and that's already got
its downfalls yeah
sugar and alcohol that's just too many
yeah no i don't know i've never people
always ask me like oh you've never drank
like oh you've never drinking water in
my life i've never i've never had the
desire to drink okay if that makes sense
i've never seen everyone around me
drinks like all of my friends growing up
for drink like we would go to events and
parties and stuff and i'd be like sober
babe yay but i've just seen how it makes
people mm-hmm and not to say that every
drink or every person or that but i've
seen what it can do and it just put me
off from a very young age and i was like
even though i wasn't knowledgeable as to
why we don't drink in islam or anything
like that just off the base of life
experiences and seeing how other people
are when they're not sober i said
no this is not for me
because god forbids i ever embarrass
myself like that no
no and that's that's what i realized too
i was just like what am i doing this for
like you act stupid
and ever sorry to cut you off everybody
that i've spoken to that drinks has said
to me if you've never drank it's not
worth it like just don't do it it's not
worth it that's i'm a big believer in
not opening like pandora's box yeah you
can't if you cannot because like for
example um i always say i've never seen
corn
i've never seen it and i won't ever
watch it yeah even though they've been
asking me for a reaction channel tonight
i think it would be very funny guys that
would be very entertaining
but no may ski i will not be doing that
on patreon
but like but like i i just like why
would you open that box it's addicting
yeah because what i've heard so like why
open a door if you could not open it and
not because for me there's always a part
of me that wants to drink and it's taken
me years to like get to the point where
i can just have like i don't care yeah
but it took me so long to get to that
path and the longer you do something the
harder it is to break exactly and so i'm
lucky where i like at 21 was like you
know what
like that was when i started like
cutting back and like getting to the
point where i could be sober but you
know a lot of people do it for a decade
and then try to quit it's like
impossible at that point you've been
doing it for 10 years yeah exactly it's
all the same and it's it's the idea of
once you get a taste of that feeling
it's over for you not to say you can
never quit but it's just hard because
you know you've opened up pandora's box
you know what that sensation or that
feeling is like you're going to learn to
crave it you're going to want to do it
more and numb yourself and x y and z
whether it's for pleasure whether it's
to deal with certain things and then it
just makes sobriety boring
you know and i think that's also another
reason why a lot of people struggle with
that because would you ever go back to
south south africa you said uh north
africa north north 100 would you ever go
there to like find a husband interesting
because i just i'm thinking like of this
from your point of view right and i'm
just like gosh that's gotta be so hard
dating in the west when you come from a
more traditional background yeah i think
um and you want you want a guy that's
like the same religion as you i don't i
don't know how big the muslim community
is in london it might be huge i have no
idea it's it's not massive but um the
asian muslim community is really big
here because um the asian community have
been in for generations like i'm first
generation
so my parents came here and then i was
born here um would i ever go back home
to find a husband i would never rule it
out okay i would never like go out
intentionally to be like oh my god i
need to find me a husband take me home
but i would never rule it out because
it's always easier to be with someone
that understands whether it's cultural
or faith or whatever but you have a
common ground it makes everything so
much easier um
i just think as long as your moral
compass is there and you know what
you're what you believe in and what your
faith is and it aligns with mine then
it's free game you know
i was just thinking that's got to be
hard like coming from a traditional
household but you still grew up in the
west that's do you know what i mean so
it's like it's like
the identity crisis that you go through
as a young muslim like woman man
whatever or just any form of minority
especially if you're first generation
is crazy because you know you're told
that you can't do this this and this
whether it's in the house or outside the
house and then you know you're made to
feel different outside the house and
also in the house because you don't fit
in externally but then when you come
home and try and fit in you don't fit in
there and it's just a whole lot and i
think human beings were made to be
balanced
and when you take something that's so
away from its natural
inclination
and it's it's raised there you know it's
born and raised there and it's being
nurtured there the battle between what
you're naturally inclined to and now
what you're being taught and what you're
being nurtured into you need to learn to
find that center
and a lot of people can't and a lot of
people don't know how to find that
balance and i get it because it's not
easy at all it's really hard
but it's just yeah i think you know i
didn't choose to be bored here it just
happened it was the cards you're dealt
you know what i mean
um but yeah
authoritarians which they are you're
saying someone who's trying to work out
their gender identity who may well have
struggled with that had quite a tough
time struggling with it you're comparing
them with you know chairman mao who no
just saw the deaths of millions of
people just even if the activists you
know they're trans people too they have
a right to say these things yeah but
they don't have a right
to their whole community compare them to
chairman mao
you know i could pinochet or gusto
punisher i mean you know this is grossly
insensitive i didn't compare them to
pinochet well i did compare an authority
he was an authoritarian he was a
right-winger though i was comparing them
to the left-wing totalitarians
and i do believe they are left-wing
totalitarians under mao millions of
people died right i mean there's no
comparison between a mao and a trans
activist is there
why not
because trans activists aren't killing
millions of people
the philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same philosophy
consequences are yet
you're saying that trans activists could
lead to the deaths of millions of people
no i'm saying that the philosophy that
drives their utterances is the same
philosophy that already has driven us to
the deaths of millions okay tell us how
that philosophy
is in any way comparable
sure that's no problem the first thing
is is that the philosophy presumes that
group identity is paramount
that's the fundamental philosophy that
drove the soviet union and maoist china
and it's the fundamental philosophy of
the left-wing activists it's identity
politics it doesn't matter who you are
as an individual it matters who you are
in terms of your group identity you're
just saying murder also to provoke
aren't you i mean you are a provocative
you want to stir things up i'm only a
provocateur in so far as
when i say what i believe to be true
it's provocative i don't provoke
maybe for you don't sit out now and then
i'm not interested in provoking but what
about the thing about you know
fighting and the lobster tell us about
the lobster
well that's quite a segway well the
first chapter i have in my book
is called stand up straight with your
shoulders back and it's an injunction to
be combative
um
not least to further your career let's
say
but also to adopt
a stance of ready engagement with the
world and to reflect that in your
posture and the reason that i
write about lobsters is because there's
this idea that hierarchical structures
are a
sociological construct of the western
patriarchy and that is so untrue that
it's almost unbelievable and i use the
lobster as an example because the
lobster we we
divulged from lobsters in evolutionary
history about 350 million years ago
common ancestor and lobsters exist in
hierarchies and have a nervous system
attuned to the hierarchy and that
nervous system runs on serotonin just
like our nervous systems do and the
nervous system of the lobster and the
human being is so similar that
antidepressants work on lobsters and
it's part of my attempt to demonstrate
that the idea of hierarchy has
absolutely nothing to do with
sociocultural construction which it
doesn't let me just get straight you're
saying that we should organize our
societies
along the lines of the lobsters
i'm saying that it's inevitable that
there will be continuity in the way that
animals and human beings organize
organize their structures it's it's
absolutely inevitable and there is
one-third of a billion years of
evolutionary history behind that right
that's that's so long that a third of a
billion years ago there weren't even
trees
it's a long time you have a mechanism in
your brain that runs on serotonin that's
similar to the lobster mechanism that
tracks your status
and the higher your status the better
your emotions are regulated so as your
serotonin levels increase you feel more
positive emotion and less negative
emotion so you're saying like the
lobsters we're hardwired as men and
women to do certain things to sort of
run along tram lines and there's nothing
we can do about it no i'm not saying
there's nothing we can do about it
because it's like a in a chess game
right there's lots of things that you
can do although you can't break the
rules of the chess game and continue to
play chess
biological your biological nature is
somewhat like that is it sets the rules
of the game but within those rules you
have a lot of leeway but the idea that
but
one thing we can't do is say that
hierarchical organization is a
consequence of the capitalist patriarchy
it's like that's patently absurd it's
wrong it's not a matter of opinion it's
seriously wrong
aren't you just whipping people up into
a state of anger and not at all
divisions between men and women you're
stirring people up you know you have any
critics of you online get absolutely
lambasted by your followers
generally
sorry your critics get lambasted by you
i mean they're irresponsible not at all
if an academic is going to come after me
and tell me that i'm not qualified and
that i'm not i don't know what i'm
talking about so you're not gonna say to
your followers now quit the abuse quit
the anger
well we'd need some
substantial examples of the abuse and
the anger before i could detail that
question there's a lot of outcome
for well let's take a more general
perspective on that so i've had 25 000
letters since june something like that
from people who told me that i've
brought them back from the brink of
destruction and so i'm perfectly willing
to put that up against the rather vague
accusations that my followers are making
the lives of people that i've targeted
miserable jordan peterson thank you
my pleasure nice talking with you
she didn't know she was about to be one
of them
[Laughter]
what do you think jordan peterson this
is one of the interviews that like put
him on the map this took conservative
media by storm yeah i
think there's a lot that we can learn
from him i think it's okay to disagree
there's certain things that you're going
to disagree on when it comes to people
and opinions and their lifestyles
um i think he talks some sense where
like to admit or not yeah there's some
sense behind what he's saying because
he's not just speaking an opinion he
said this is fact like there's no
agreeing or disagree like this is what
the outcome will be this is what it is
it's been proven by all these other
things and it makes sense i'm just like
was there anything you disagreed with on
the video i don't think so yes it's
pretty it's which is i'm a bit
shocked because normally there would
always be a thing or two but no but then
that just goes to prove my point i think
yeah that yeah he makes a lot of sense
um and just learn to filter through
compartmentalize what you're taking in
and you'll be fine and that's that's
what i like is you're very much if you
hear information you're not arguing to
argue you'll listen yeah that's why i
always i try to bring people that i
think will like not get mad at me no
honey
yelling at the screen
no i'd be shocked
i've been doing this for months now
anyways
anyways guys go um where's your podcast
on my podcast is on youtube it's um
conscious conversations with visuals
it's also on spotify and apple music
yeah i'm probably to go on in the next
couple months yes
i'm going through the london podcast
scene so you'll catch me
alright guys like the video on your way
out let me know in the comments what you
want to see us react to next time and we
will talk to you later